[Applaudissements]
patrick a fait monsieur courage mais
assez mature soucieux
mathieu à votre avis pourquoi j'ai
accepté de remplacer le pakistanais le
vendredi soir parce que vous avez été
viré comme une merde de france mis
d'accord mais notre horizon pourtant de
la place à sanaa
exact et c'était en train de marcher et
je suis entrain de m'apercevoir comme
chroniqueur à la même des deux mois et
je ne vais pas le laisser faire lequel
j'ai oublié son nom à celui qui qui
ressemble à conchita woerth
exactement
il est jeune il est beau avec un peu de
chance et les courses trois qualités
pour réussir à la télé voilà pourquoi
c'est notre ennemi alors on va tout de
suite passer à l'attaqué
c'est un petit port qu'on donne aux
enfants c'est ce qu'il prend à son repas
tous les soirs vers 17h30 avant le
direct vous allez lui mettre dans sa
loge et j'ai mis du laxatifs à
l'intérieur à mon avis sa rubrique
devrait dépoter
enfin vous pensez bien que j'ai essayé
le petit poule l'accepter vraiment
ça va bertrand vous avez passé ont donc
tout un week-end ex écrin fabrice j'ai
regardé toutes mes chroniques de la
semaine précédente en replay donc vous
dire que j'ai passé un sale quart
d'heure à une vanne de rôle du coup pour
me changer les idées j'ai mis france de
la fête de la musique patrick sébastien
c'était à nice formidable ils assurent
qu'ils tombent hanouna et les dollars
j'en peux plus je change de chaîne
canal+ salut les terriens ardisson
j'adore et là sur qui tombe hanouna le
mec et par toujours peu plus bompas
canet vous bertrand va se mettre un peu
de musique la savane ou remonter
[Musique]
et oui parce que c'est aujourd'hui que
sort tpmn la coupe il est raide fabrics
oui ça y est pas en train de faire la
promo pour l'album du patron l'a peu
près du tout c'est juste que je pense à
l'année prochaine
bon allez bertrand je vais vous remonter
le moral j'ai une blague c'est
l'histoire d'une chaîne nrj 12 qui a
rentré va lancer une émission
scientifique et les nazis ou coquin de
sort bertrand
regardez julien combes est absent toute
la semaine de tpm pays mais ça veut dire
que la voie est libre pour l'émission du
vendredi
c'est pour moi eh ben non parce que
enora remplace julien courbet à la
présentation vendredi c'est pas vous
quoi il n'aura nous reste combien de
temps ne m'a fait mission noble mission
[Musique]
elle était alors fabrice et les 20
heures ça y est le résultat des tv notes
pure médias va tomber on va enfin savoir
qui est le meilleur chrono du cadre de
la saison c'est le meilleur chroniqueur
et [ __ ] camille combal à 24,5 pour
cent mais c'est pas bien bertrand
regardez vous est deuxième avec 24 3%
abbas est un petit poêle de poils un
poil de cul en parlons franchement 0,2
pour cent
si voulez mon avis il ya quelque chose
de louche
l'écart de voix qui me séparent de
camille combal est extrêmement faible
il s'agit pour moi ni plus ni moins d'un
coup médiatique une manoeuvre visant une
fois de plus à me déstabiliser
je remets ici en cause la fiabilité du
système informatique du site pure médias
c'est pourquoi je demande officiellement
un recomptage
s'il vous plaît je demande un recomptage
des voix ainsi que l'organisation d'une
nouvelle élection la semaine prochaine
il en va de la dignité de notre système
médiatique
je vous remercie vote de merde [ __ ] 0
2 0 2 0 à bertrand bertrand qu'à me dois
de réagir
il n'y a aucune compétition avec
bertrand jean leroy oui aucune complète
aucune compets culma poteau tape un peu
de thunes l'amd pas n'est pas ce qu'il
me manque des pièces pour prendre un
café web enfin ça dépend combien 0,2
euro tard est super classe s'achemine
c'est quoi ces deux là c'est gentil non
ces belles shimon sa tête je connais
bien la boutique un jeu peut-être
d'abord il rit genre je sais pas 0,2
pour cent c'est con quand même à 0,2 cm
était pour moi